new trailer were bringing the team
together so new trailer dropped for
Avengers infinity war and I don't
personally have a ton of stuff to say
about it that I didn't say about the
first teaser that came out a little
while back but I know whoever wants to
expect the video so I brought Liz so
we're gonna talk about it together yeah
I I wash I think three times you just
watched it first the first time cuz I
probably dropped when I was at work or
something to do you gainfully employed
when a new trailer was coming out what
is wrong with you oh all right
kindergarteners we got stop what we're
doing stop this book we're gonna watch
math doesn't matter you'll never you'll
never use that you need this he needs to
get like all the rings and all the
stones yeah okay and they like shiny
things so yeah there's got to be a
teacher out there that that is
integrating the the Marvel Universe into
their teaching curricula like collecting
them all I guess I didn't see it but
there was a quote from a Pokemon today
when they were giving a there they do
morning meeting every Friday and the
quote of the morning or the quote of the
week was from a Pokemon it's gonna hurt
I'll have to look I'll have to ask them
what it was we have managed to tangent
right back okay that all out I won't
because that would be effort so I I know
you had seen the teaser trailer because
it played ahead of black panther when we
went and saw that so it wasn't like you
were seeing this concept for the first
time but what do you think of trailer I
really like that I'm excited to get the
whole team together
really excited because the guardians of
the galaxy they're so weird and
wonderful in their own little snarky
team I'm really excited for them to meet
all the Avengers and merge with these
guys and sure he was in it the incident
I saw her the drug like please gonna
lose it yeah sure yeah not there wasn't
enough Cherie but there was there's a
little bit of shirt it's a big cast
there probably won't be enough Cherie
for you in this movie if we're being
honest yeah I like other people in the
cast here oh good it's funny my not
enough Hulk either there but I mean
they're well know movies out in a month
they're probably done rendering him by
now for most of it but the what I was
gonna say he's since you brought up
guardians of the galaxy it was
interesting because I hadn't thought too
much about it but see him star-lord
play against somebody like Tony Stark
and realizing man these guys really are
their own thing this there's gonna be a
lot of interesting interactions going on
here cuz I cuz they can barely get true
with the Avengers they just had like
their last thing they had was pretty
much a civil war yes I mean but even
taking that into account I'm not sure
there's anyone on the planet who
actually lived on the planet Earth
through would have looked Tony Stark in
the face and go I like your plan except
it sucks I'm not sure if there's anyone
who actually lives on earth or who would
have said that like Captain America
would have said that I mean they wanted
to use the word sucks he may he may have
expressed the sentiment but he wouldn't
know it wouldn't have been the
combination of that thought in those
words from anybody else well sure he
would have been like colonizers all
these broken white boys there's gonna be
a lot of them after this movie I think
this is true she's gonna have a lot of
people to fix I know
we only got a glimpse of something that
I wasn't expecting we got a tiny glimpse
of a flashback because you see we don't
see her face but we see a tiny little
Gamora with a nose like this little
green hand around his giant friggin
finger and I'm like okay I was not
expecting flashback material in this
alright like Gamora voiceover and it
makes I'm I'm I like her and I I'm
always open to more information with her
and I liked that she has all this
information and kind of has to step up
as a leader which she's quite capable of
and sort of say okay here's who he is
who this is who were fighting again so I
don't really like that we have a sailor
in the trailers yet but I am expecting
nebula to come in be a complete cowboy
in a monkey wrench in this just having
blinders on and going after Thanos in in
such a way that it disrupts what
everyone else is trying to do I'm fully
expecting this that's kind of her like
single mining and things out she just
goes in and like GE oh she's a chaos and
tries to get revenge Jing she has a goal
Jeff saut a rage winning kind of quite
earth thing no not her thing um so yeah
good to see her I love the ending with
Spider Man and Doctor Strange silver is
really adorable
he-man this entire days oh I did not see
that Andrew Garfield's
spider-man movies but I love this Peter
I love Tom Holland that's the same guy
yep okay um so much more than Tobey
Maguire I do honestly love the three I
think I actually agree I like Tom
Holland the best I Tobey Maguire was a
very good cast for a very specific
version of spider-man he was the 60s
early 70s sad sack down in his luck the
universe just craps on in Peter and he
was
good for that that's not my preferred
Peter in the first place
Andrew Garfield was very good at the
snark but they maybe kind of overdid it
almost a little bit they've all been
good at various things I like the blend
they have with Tom Holland so that that
works oh there's something I really like
about the image of him slapping on the
mask but not having the rest of the suit
so he's like swinging under the Brooklyn
Bridge with the spider-man mask and his
school clothes like clothes you know
like they need me Tony words years on
perfecting but whatever practice in my
bag that's back at the bus that's across
town you know he forgets that everywhere
like he leaves it in a taxicab like
Sierra Moses Horo does his know
spider-man I could see it I definitely
think yeah we also get a little glimpses
of the few well not the few because
we've gotten accounts for most of the
Infinity stones up to this point so you
need to refresh my memory I know dr.
strange one doctor she's dr. Sanchez he
has the time Jim no I can't imagine how
the vision has one I think his is the
mmm I can't remember my goodness sold no
idea wow I really know it's the mind Jim
I think I think he has there was the
power gem that would give that we
haven't seen here but that got left with
Nova prime at the end of the first
Guardians movie
so the Nova Corps is guarding the Hat oh
come floating mug oh no Loki has the
mind Jim because that's the tesseract
okay which we actually see fanners hold
and crush presumably to either reform it
into the gym or take the gem out of the
middle of it or some stone in the comics
their gems and the movie their stones
it's the same thing don't correct me in
the comments people who do that you know
who you are
this is like the sorcerer versus
Philosopher's Stone kinda thing
yeah little bit yeah which this is
really like I'm like this is like
keeping track of the Horcruxes it really
is who has what and what are the do and
like what form is it in and oh but
they're all pretty shiny colors yeah
that's good it's a little bit I don't I
actually can't remember who has the
ether right now last I remember the
collector had it but I can't imagine
he's hmm well maybe he didn't lose it at
the end of guardians
I mean his collection got smashed up to
heck but I don't think they accounted
for it they accounted for it actually
leaving there I don't think but the only
one not accounted for I believe it's the
soul gem now the the we don't know who
has that we don't the belief um the the
fan theory is that it's it was in the
meteor that landed in Wakanda that also
carries uranium like sure he had
something she looks like she had
something but also it's the the theory
is that it's part of the whole astral
plane thing is connected to the soul gem
being that would make sense so that's
that's fan theory if that's not what it
is they better have an even better idea
than that cuz that's a pretty good idea
really cool yeah and that's a nice
tie-in for Black Panther and his world
and sure he's gonna be in it she'll be
in it I'm pretty sure his mother's gonna
be in it yeah well I think it would be
really smart well they wouldn't know
what a huge success Black Panther was
when they made this but not when they
try to buy I think they had an inkling I
mean they went all in with would having
Black Panther be exactly what it was
gonna be they didn't they didn't do any
half-measures with that so I I think I
think they might have had a lot of they
might have had an inkling let's go back
to the condo okay guys well no we're
definitely getting some stuff actually
in Wakanda there's no doubt about that
and this one also had a bit more
focus on fan OHS himself who we who is
he played by Josh Brolin Oh yep that
makes sense yep that is Jeff Rowland now
that I can see it through all them like
chin love the CGI and the because they
make my CGI chin the the it's like just
the it's like just his chin has been
soaking in water and gotten the wrinkle
thing going on like even do just they
they just submerge his both his chin in
a bowl of water for about three about
three hours so they're apparently
keeping his kind of his goal that he's
had that he had at least four time in
the comics which was to wipe out half
the population of the entire universe
they seem to be messing slightly with
his reason for doing that though because
in this trailer that he cut he's talking
about balance and in the first trailer
he talks about rebalancing the universe
so there seems to be a more
philosophical thing he's going forward
with this in the guy in the comics he
does it because he has a crush on death
I mean literally the physical embodiment
of death he is crushing on and he's
trying to impress her and that is why he
wants to kill half the universe man it's
not the same another thing that his
obsession would be much more
understandable if it was that version of
death unfortunately it's not the perky
God it's basically just a female figure
like female silhouette in a purple robe
with a skull for a head he's in love
with that and it doesn't talk to him
well he talks enough this is true he's a
villain he monologues you know he's got
some like toxic masculinity issues
[Laughter]
I'm gonna give you applause for that one
so I do find it interesting that they're
keeping some like his iconic stuff that
he wants to do and is trying to
accomplish but it's probably smart to
take her with his reasoning for why yeah
cuz have we met death in any of the
movie I don't expect they're gonna do
the physical embodiment of death in the
MCU that the way they have in the
comments the closest we've come as we've
met hella was the goddess of death in
Ragnarok now I know I've seen fan
theories that she will be subbing for
Lady before the physical embodiment of
death from the comics because while we
saw she we last saw her on Asgard this
was for ignore
and as Ragnarok happened and the whole
thing was destroyed we didn't
definitively see her die that said I
think that's a bit of a stretch because
I think I think the folks behind the
movies know that it's it's a bit much to
have him literally in love with death
and that might that might be more than
audiences can swallow so I don't even
think they're gonna have he'll a
substitute I just don't think they're
gonna go there I think it's feasible I
also feel like they're kind of getting
away from the like love stories in the
MCU like there's a little hidden black
panther there was really none and thor
ragnarok know and like it was kind of
there in spider-man I mean it was high
school crush stuff seasons but it wasn't
like the married I mean he met MJ but
like yeah I'm all suspect for that their
spoiler yeah it's the it was a trailer
for infinity war and you can't really
complain it is for spoiling the movies
that came before this I'm travelling was
I wish we had seen nebula I would have
liked that but I'm kind of
kind of excited that I don't know what
she's up to that's true it'll be like we
won't know what she's up to when she
comes in I'm trying to think who else I
was surprised that we got what looks to
be teenage group I thought he was gonna
be more or less full-grown by the time
we got to this I know he's pretty much
at the same state we saw him at the end
of guardians of the galaxy - would John
I'm okay with that
yeah I'd like to see more of that um we
know what full girls like baby I'm gonna
miss baby Cruz and nasty he's a nasty
little yeah and which makes him even
somehow more adorable he is tantrums
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
so there was again I think my worry is
this cast is going to be too big and
there's certain characters I love and
certain characters I'm like mad about
and because they have to fit everyone in
I'm gonna be like but I want more of
them so that is my I think major worry
with it also I hope they give a lot of
like backstory to Gamora Adonis and
everything because I want to like really
get into him as a villain oh wow I mean
they they have been building up to fan o
since the end of the first avenger so
that was 2012 Berlin you better bring it
well he better bring it in the movie
better really justify this guy having
been lurking in the background for
what'll have been six years it's because
we first got him in the first guardians
of the galaxy right when he first showed
up in the in the film he showed up in
the mid credits stinger at the end of
the first Avengers that was a first
glimpse way I definitely remember that
yep so it there's there's a fair amount
worried because otherwise the build-up
will feel like it's not much now what
what you talked about like worried about
your favorite characters not getting as
much spotlight as you want unfortunate
that's kind of a
the dice you roll with any sort of big
it like to just talk about comics any
big event or big crossover not
everyone's gonna get equal time some
people are well that person is just
happy to be there and that's that's kind
of what happened we can deal with that
for some characters but yeah I I'm not
too worried cuz I think they know how to
make this a big event I think they know
how to do that they did a good job with
the other Avengers movies and with civil
war I think but I I was recently
watching Civil War and I was just like
there's too many people there's too much
going on like it was a little much for
me and this is I feel like going to be
even more so like I'll enjoy it and I'll
like seeing all the characters but I
won't love it as much as some of the
like movies that focus on the individual
superheroes I mean and that's a valid
concern and I think for me like to make
the comparison to Captain America Civil
War I think for me Captain America
America Civil War works and gets away
with it because it does primarily focus
on Bucky cap and Tony and it has a lot
of other people in there but that's your
core story so I'm not sure who the core
characters are gonna be that this one's
gonna focus on more is gonna be the more
god I mean she and I and I'm all for
that she's got she's got to be one um
I would I would say pretty decent shot
at either Tony or cap being one
depending on which one of them they
decide to kill off cuz I don't see both
of them living to the end of this I do
too but somebody's well it's probably
gonna be telling me he's been fading oh
here's the thing somebody's gonna die
but what I'm really worried about and
this is what a lot of fans are
predicting a lot of fans want this I
don't is that somebody's got to die and
then after they defeat Thanos they'll
use the Infinity Gauntlet to undo the
death of well
that will take me off if they do that
yeah so we'll see but we haven't had a
lot of death like major character we've
had almost none we've had spoiler a
Quicksilver yeah and I'm trying to think
of that basically it's been it's been
Quicksilver and it's been people who
were always going to die like last time
I brought this up people mention like
Youssef in the first Ironman like yeah
but he's supposed to die that's like is
even he's the guy in the cave who helps
Tony build uh that guy was always gonna
die I mean that that's like saying Oh
Uncle Ben died Uncle Ben has to die
that's his function so we don't even
have it in this rendering him MCU here
already gone so like we what we have
have we have had a fair number of
fake-out deaths we've had like three
with Loki alone we've had no I won't say
it because then everyone else we've had
a fake-out death with Nick Fury it's
yeah we've had a very villain we've had
some villains die but I mean you know
who I want you to bring back plate he
won't happen cuz it was really well done
Black Panther but man I'm gonna miss him
missing kill monger alright yeah it was
really good oh yeah but yeah I think
I've covered what I had was there
anything you disliked or like no no I
quit you not really what why I was
nervous and I hadn't been sure that I
was gonna watch this trailer initially
because my policy lately with movies
that I know I'm going to the theater to
see no matter what is to watch the first
teaser and then if I can stop myself not
watch any of the ones after that because
after that the one side once I know I'm
going to see this anything else that I
watch just has the potential to spoil me
on stuff so and something
I've been able to maintain that would I
maintain that with Star Wars the last
Jedi and spider-man homecoming and thor
ragnarok Oh
MC you like rocking it out recently it
is but but those were sort of my three
major wins of movies that I saw the
first shot and literally cut myself off
from the marketing after this one I
heard from enough people that this
trailer did not give a ton of stuff that
wasn't in some way into that in the
initial teaser anyway and I think that's
true and I for one really appreciate
that so even though it feels like it's
giving more more of a sense of the plot
it also does not feel like it was
showing any particular segment that
wasn't at least hinted at in the first
one so I didn't feel like I was getting
anything spoiled for me by watching this
additional trailer I'm probably done
though for the record so when they come
out with it coming out really soon may
end of April they moved it forward I
forgot the so yeah so I've got about a
month I'm sure they'll do at least one
more trailer I'm not watching it yeah no
I'm not thank you I have all three power
because I edit or I would if I wasn't
lazy I am she does know so yes I am very
excited as well I'm really excited that
this like shows more about Gamora and
I'm I'm in very intrigued by that I
think that is my new take away from this
that wasn't really in the other trailer
and it's just good to see them all
especially Sheree yeah
I'm excited and I'm always excited to
see spider-man again he's just so much
fun and adorable and
yeah I wonder when is it and when is the
new spider-man I don't think it has a
date yet
they're they're work they're working on
it I mean um but I think I think that
will wrap it up for this one folks so
thanks so much for joining us we do a
podcast together called punch like a
girl there'll be a link for that down
below plus a link for all the other
stuff I do like my patreon it you can
buy t-shirts follow me on Twitter and
all that stuff so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]